bonjour bienvenue dans génération europe
nous sommes ici à la cité internationale
universitaire de paris au collège franco
britannique avec les étudiants européens
qui sont derrière moi nous allons parler
des frontières de l'europe
jusqu'où va t-elle se sera aussi avec
notre invité qui va nous rejoindre
edouard martin
et bonjour à vous tous alors l'union
européenne ça remonte à 1957 en 57 ans
on est passé de 6 à 28 est ce que vous
vous souvenez chacun d'entre vous soit
personnellement soit histoire de famille
comment on a basculé au niveau de son
pays dans l'europe
elisa toit par exemple la bulgarie ce
temps 2007 oui c'est très récent
oui c'est très simple ça fait six ans
que la bulgarie fait partie de l'union
européenne au moment de l'adhésion
c'était plutôt une joie d'ordre
idéologique liées au programme
néolibéral aujourd'hui je pense que vu
l'effondrement sociale je ne sais pas si
les gens sont toujours sur eux
dutoit chloé tu te souviens d'en avant
après pour chip c'était en 2004 donc on
avait vraiment vécu ça comme une joie on
a fait la fête toute la soirée au
restaurant chypriote de maison donc
voila mais pour ma mère qui est réfugiés
de la guerre de 1974 c'était vraiment
pour elle une sorte de protection de
rentrer dans l'union européenne fasse un
voisin assez instable qui est la turquie
on reparlera la turquie bien entendu
tout à l'heure james toi c'était quoi
l'entr'aide du ministère soit 113
dentelle je n'étais pas né c'était
plutôt mes parents qui ont des souviens
je crois que on a été plutôt adressées
par le doublé de toute façon quoi qu'il
en soit encore aujourd'hui change pas
d'autres voyages en local oui bah nous
nous on est candidat entre guillemets
des pionniers d union européenne donc
l'italie
moi je n'ai pas nés quand l'italie y
entrer mais je me souviens que puisque
j'habite à 20 km de la slovénie
puisqu'il ya eu la guerre pendant les 90
la moment la frontière c'était la
frontière donc au détail avaient
n'importe quoi et quand les barrières la
la la la douane avec la zone i a été
effacée entre les mains puisque la zone
ligne et entrer à l'union européenne
c'est tomber la tension en fait parce
que chaque fois qu'on allait là il y
avait les flics à la frontière et quand
on a vu disparaître bien effik et la
frontière aussi là ça a changé je crois
dans la quotidienneté 2
de tout le monde oui quand on parle de
frontières il ya un détail qu'on n'a pas
qu'on n'a pas soulevé ici mais je pense
que c'est parce qu'on a toujours vécu on
n'a jamais connu la difficulté de
traverser une frontière avec une balle
mais en dehors de l'europe à chaque fois
qu'on veut se rendre dans notre pays il
faut obtenir un visa
ces deux démarches voilà compliqué on
est tous confrontés quand on veut aller
aux états unis quand on veut sortir
grave on est dans un espace qui est une
forme de liberté
on va voir quelles sont les façons de
délimiter cet espace on a la chance
d'être in qu'est ce que c'est d'être en
dehors et comment s'est créé justement
vague par vagues
l'évolution de l'union européenne on va
retracer tout ça tout de suite grâce à
thiais richard s'est mise en image par
hugo nicolas fait l'essentiel
depuis sa création en 1957 l'union
européenne et à géographie variable
les frontières ne font que ces tirs et
on compte six vagues d'élargissement
1973 les six états fondateurs france
italie belgique allemagne pays bas
luxembourg accueille trois nouveaux
venus
le royaume-uni le danemark et l'irlande
1981 entrée de la grèce 1986 c'est au
tour de l'espagne et du portugal
en 1990 réunification de l'allemagne est
arrivée de l'ancienne allemagne de l'est
1995 arrivé de l'autriche de la finlande
et de la suède 2004 dit nouveau d'un
coup pologne lituanie lettonie estonie
hongrie république tchèque slovaquie
slovénie chypre et malte suivis en 2007
de la roumanie et de la bulgarie
et le petit dernier la croatie date de
juillet dernier voilà comment on passe
de 6 à 28 ans presque 60 ans et ça
continue de frapper à la porte
cinq pays sont entrés dans un processus
officielle d'adhésion mais sans date
d'entrée prévu il s'agit de l'islande de
la macédoine du monténégro de la serbie
et de la turquie
l'albanie a simplement déposer sa
candidature quand à la bosnie
herzégovine et le kosovo deux autres
républiques de l'ancienne yougoslavie
leurs candidatures sont attendues les
critères d'adhésion ont été définis à
copenhague en 1993 qui exige notamment
une démocratie stable l'état de droit la
protection des minorités et une économie
de marché concurrentielle
quand on entend la définition des
différents critères d'admission qui sont
la démocratie stable l'état de droit
protection des minorités économie marché
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de notre invité
qui aujourd'hui edouard martin qui est
candidat et qui conduit la liste
socialiste aux élections européennes
dans le grand est bon jour
vous les avez un petit peu entendu
attentifs regard des autres c'est
intéressant alors mon point de vue
simplement sur ce qu'est l'europe en
tout cas ce que devrait mettre l'europe
c'est d'abord et avant tout un projet
politique
le projet politique c'est comment on
crée un espace alors après on va
échanger sur quelles sont les frontières
qu'on peut accepter mais c'est le vivre
ensemble quoi la création de l'europe
d'abord c'était il faut jamais l'oublier
même si on n'a pas connu et on espère
qu'on ne connaîtra jamais c'est après la
deuxième guerre mondiale où les pères
fondateurs ont dit après les massacres
qu'on a connue s'est plus jamais ça or
aujourd'hui nous sommes en guerre
économique
c'est pas les mêmes massacre mais il ya
des gens qui sont sur le bord de la
route
souffrant en souffrance et donc est ce
que l'europe dans la question que j'ai
envie de débattre avec vous c'est
l'europe pour qui est l'europe pourquoi
et moi j'ai envie d'une europe où on est
des règles de de vivre ensemble sait où
on est on est sur cette terre entre
guillemets je faire un peu de religion
c'est pourquoi faire que je dirons
quelles religions
je suis athée donc ça tombe bien donc
c'est simplement c'est quoi ces amasser
un maximum de richesses au détriment des
autres voilà c'est une europe de
solidarité c'est aussi une europe du
partage évidemment on n'est pas dans le
monde de bisounours mais il faut pas non
plus que ce soit comme on a parfois
tendance à personne actuellement une
europe où c'est moins disant social kg
porte le reste c'est aussi une des
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai accepté de
m'engager en politique et notamment sur
les européennes c'est pour essayer ça va
pas être simple parce qu'aujourd'hui le
parlement européen est plutôt libérale
et ils basent beaucoup l'accent sur
libre-échange concurrence non juste une
info c'est enfin bref on ne peut pas
accepter que l'europe se construit
uniquement en tirant le reste vers le
bas à chaque fois et ça c'est le fil
conducteur de l'europe et et vous pouvez
regarder dans l'histoire européenne car
60 ans aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu'un
pays à intégrer l'union européenne on a
vu le niveau
vie de ses concitoyens s'élever ça c'est
le fil conducteur de l'europe il faut
pas maintenant inverser la courbe et
faire en sorte qu'aujourd'hui une europe
ne pourrait exister que parce que on a
des salaires moins cher parce qu'on a
plus de protection sociale etc
la question qui se pose sur les
frontières de leur avoue du coup c'est
de savoir à ce que l'union européenne
doit s'agrandir encore à mon avis la
question de l'élargissement et des
frontières afin ça pose évidemment ça
pose de questions en fait ça pose la
question de la maîtrise des frontières
mais c'est surtout sa pause à
l'intérieur enfin la question de quelle
europe on veut et effectivement enfin
moi j'ai l'impression que depuis 2004
si on a autant élargi c'était évidemment
pour favoriser un marché plus que un
approfondissement politique et donc
évidemment là dessus on a envie de dire
que le rêve européen a été un peu voilà
sacrifié sur l'autel d'un élargissement
qui étaient là juste pour effectivement
les marchés européens plus flexible si
vous salue ça marchait bien et du coup
c'est vrai qu'avant 2005 et 2004 la
situation économique était quand même
bonne et du coup je pense que à
bruxelles ont séduit va autant c'est
vrai tous les autres pays chez qui ça
marche peut-être moins bien et puis du
coup leur haut niveau de vie pourrait
augmenter au toit qui est belge moi qui
suis belge pour rebondir sur
l'intervention de louly moi j'ai envie
de vous poser une question sur martin
est-ce que vous pensez que c'était
largement qui a été assez rapide
d'après certains est un obstacle à cette
solidarité entre les peuples que vous
aimeriez voir et si du coup on n'a pas
fragiliser d'une certaine manière le
projet européen
on élargit son nom c'est pas une
affirmation si vous voulez je vous pose
moi je n'ai pas de
de conduire de religion là dessus mais
là où je suis d'accord je pense qu'on
était très vite pour ces pays là je veux
dire et on l'a vu aussi avec la roumanie
entre autres pas que la pologne ce
terrain où à peine une dizaine d'années
après la chute du mur de berlin
ils ont intégré l'europe ils ont
découvert des gens pris en pleine figure
ce qu'est le libéralisme la concurrence
etc
donc je pense qu'on n'a pas il aurait
fallu un sas entre guillemets je suis
patient peuple et ça comme ça de manière
à ce qu'on vienne de manière douce si je
puis dire laisser le temps aussi à ces
pays là à s'adapter parce que du jour au
lendemain les contraindre à avoir les
mêmes les mêmes règlements les mêmes
règles et les mêmes c'est comment dire
contraintes que les que les pays qui
sont depuis 40 50 ans c'est pas évident
mais ça s'est plutôt bien passé surtout
c'est pas du tout ça s'est plutôt bien
passé mais dix ans après en disant voilà
les roumains étaient ravis d'intégrer
d'une heure aux peines et c'était leur
bouée de sauvetage presque voilà enfin
avant de démocratie on était sûr qu'une
fois à téhéran l'union européenne il
aurait pu se risque d'un retour en
arrière
néanmoins la vraie question c'est de
savoir est ce qu'on fait l'europe avec
les peuples sans le peuple est là parce
que je viens régulièrement roumanie
quand je discute avec mes collègues
roumains
est ce là où je me dit quelque part
l'europe a loupé quelque chose c'est
qu'il ya des gens de plus en plus qui
commence à regretter l'époque communiste
quand les gens il faut les entendre
parce que le problème de l'europe
l'impression qu'elle donne et des fois
c'est même c'est justifié
c'est que l'europe avance sans le sang
les peuples qu'entendait de des
collègues roumains me dise moi l'époque
cole avait ceausescu il était ce qu'il
était effectivement un dictateur
sanguinaire tout ce qu'on veut mais à la
nostalgie mais non mais non c'est pas
forcément injuste ainsi de repenser le
passé et qu'on va quand même pas
shame on les écoute les images les
laisse dire que quand ils vous disent
moi à l'époque j'avais je partais
j'avais des vacances assurer tous les
ans mes enfants à la l'université
j'avais à logements j'avais un appel à
police secrète qui venait chercher mes
amis quand il y en a on est d'accord
non mais attends juste terminée vous
voyez c'est peut-être là où il ya la
différence je sais pas quelle est votre
vision à vous de l'europe jeune fille
mais la différence peut-être vous
disions la mienne c'est que moi j'ai
envie de nous laisser personne sur le
bord de la route
parce que c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
qu'on se retrouve à avoir aujourd'hui un
retour du populisme où ils disent on
était quand même vachement mieux entre
nous pour oui alors c'est à dire c'est
quelque chose qui ne rouvriront leur
pouce pour rebondir sur ce que vous
dites là je voudrais qu'on écoute tout
de suite la question de notre partenaire
de l'émission qui s'appelle atlantico
c'est jean sébastien faire jour et vous
poser une question justement sur cette
articulation là entre le social et puis
le besoin d'agrandissement d'europe
de plus 20 ans l'élargissement de
l'europe s'est fait de concert avec la
mondialisation est dans une logique de
libre-échange maintenant plusieurs
études économiques montrent que même si
l'union au global et la france en ont
bénéficié certaines catégories sociales
et notamment les ouvriers des pays
d'origine
eux ont été perdants il ya différentes
négociations d'élargissement de l'union
qui sont en cours ou de partenariats
alors j'ai une double question pour vous
d'une part est-ce qu'il faut continuer à
aller plus loin dans le fait de
repousser les frontières et deuxièmement
puisque c'est la position du parti
socialiste de le faire
comment gère-t-on la mise en concurrence
des travailleurs martin je pense que la
question faisait directement
mais effectivement je comprends pas bien
je crois comprendre vu venir la moi j'ai
aussi une question à lui poser si
j'avais face à moi est ce que les
ouvriers chinois nico ne concurrence pas
les ouvriers non mais concrètement
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire au sein de
l'europe justement pour l'europe il faut
aussi que le maître des règles sociales
et l'idée d'instaurer un smic européen
ça va dans ce sens là et simplement et
je vous le dis parce que je connais
parfaitement la boîte de là que je
travaille mittal quitte à planter sur
neuf pays européens et je vous dis je
vois bien comment ils essayent lui de
concurrencer les ouvriers les uns contre
les autres
lorsque en espagne par exemple le
gouvernement c'est ce tel code du
travail et qu'il autorise une entreprise
uniquement parce que le chiffre
d'affaires baisse à faire un plan social
et qui devient accrue chantage si vous
n'acceptez pas de réduire vos salaires
de 10% et d'augmenter votre travail de
15% et bien je n'investirai puis en
espagne et que les ouvriers bas face à
cette menace accepte suppression veut
dire inacceptable et après ils viennent
au luxembourg en belgique en france et
de dire regardez d espagne ont accepté a
pas de raison que vous n'acceptez pas
dire quoi l'argent des règles je suis
d'abord vers vous penseriez quoi mais ça
veut dire qu'il faut des règles et
empêcher ce genre de galles genre de
réel qu'est ce qu'on peut un minimum
c'est à dire qu'il est il est impensable
j'ai pris ce qu'on me le dire il est
interdit que des grandes multinationales
comme ça face le chantage à l'emploi en
tirant toujours le droit des
travailleurs le droit de la société
parce qu en définitive c'est toute la
société qui est impactée - moins de
salaires c'est-à-dire moins d'impôts
moins de taxes indirectes - le service
public était donc c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné il faut des règles
minimales haut en dessous desquels les
grandes multinationales parce que elle
elle voit bien aujourd'hui les failles
de l'union européenne il n'y a pas de
règles minimum
elle joue là dessus c'est pas l'europe
qui met en concurrence les ouvriers les
uns contre les autres ce sont les
multinationales qui profitent du système
mais il faut pas oublier qu'on est dans
une économie mondialisée déjà l'europe
dépensent le plus dans le monde sur les
conditions sociales et si on impose aux
multinationales des conditions ils vont
aller ailleurs et c'est ou ailleurs les
états unis
jean en chine vous êtes payé 100 dollars
par mois vous triez 60 heures par
semaine et j'avais surtout un droit de
se former votre bouche c'est pas la
société qui me fait rêver je suis désolé
je vous avais parlé
vous avez de concurrence sauvage et de
guerre économique
mais enfin la politique de concurrence
de la commission européenne ces
événements la même force contre les
grandes multinationales peut mieux faire
beaucoup mieux faire que ma main je vous
donne quand ferme les yeux des produits
venant d'ailleurs qui ne respectent
aucune règle environnementale sociale
financière etc
l'europe ne peut pas accepter ça c'est
là où je dis que c'est le rôle politique
de l'europe est très important l'europe
doit imposer ces normes
est ce que c'est ce qui nous
construisent les normes
environnementales sociales et politiques
mairie pourquoi il ne s'agit pas de
faire du protectionnisme idiot bête
c'est ce que j'appelle moi le juste
équilibre aux frontières et ça ça va
obliger ces continents là justement à
élever le niveau social de 2 de ce pays
c'est ça aussi le rôle de l'europe
edouard martin le rôle de l'europe à
l'étranger il est réel maintenant si on
reste à l'intérieur de nos frontières on
a vu qu'on a abordé différemment la
façon dont certains pays avaient été
intégrées bonnes choses mauvaises choses
faut-il en intégrer davantage
voilà je vous propose maintenant
d'aborder le cas de la turquie on va
regarder tout de suite un reportage que
vous avez fait vous elisa comment ça
s'est passé
c'est une journée curieuse et j'allais
sur de la turquie c'est quelque chose
qui a une question quotidienne en tant
que bulgares ou pas forcément oui oui
c'est un débat c'est un débat bulgare
débat européen
moi j'ai rencontré lors c'est pas vital
quoi c'est pas aussi vital que
on pourrait avoir l'impression pour la
bulgarie écoute on va regarder le
reportage on en reparle à ce que préfère
elisa à paris ce sont ces cinémas normal
pour une fan de la nouvelle vague et
lizard 24 ans était étudiant en droit et
en langues et nous vient tout droit de
sofia bulgarie un pays voisin de la
turquie
je sais pas si on voit les symboles tout
en haut de la tour eiffel mais en tout
cas ça fait des années que la turquie
frappe à la porte de l'europe
après des années de blocage les
négociations d'entrée ont repris alors
la turquie membre de l'union européenne
demain on fait le point
et qu'en pensent les intéressés
direction le quartier turc dans le 10e
arrondissement de paris est ce que vous
êtes pour l'entrée de la turquie en
europe bien sûr je suis en forme je sais
tout mon coeur voilà donc comme
difficile de trouver ici un turc
eurosceptiques firent du dynamisme de
leur pays le premier argument du
plaidoyer pro européen est économique
il y a une chose si la turquie
l'entrelacs l'europe très grande chance
pour l'europe parce qu'ils la turquie
maintenant il fait beaucoup de commerces
avec irak moyen-orient jusqu'à la chine
la turquie maintenant c'est vraiment
très ouvert
commencée il ya près de 20 ans le
processus d'adhésion de la turquie est
le plus long qui ait jamais existé
l'allemagne bloqué et la france avec
nicolas sarkozy avait opposé son veto un
veto levé en octobre dernier par
françois hollande qui a même fait le
voyage à rukara en janvier dernier alors
où en est la france sur ce dossier
épineux et lisa est sur le coup un
processus d'adhésion entre la turquie et
l'union européenne est engagée
la france est favorable à ce que ce
processus se poursuive
donc il ya une vraie volonté
d'accueillir la turquie au sein de
l'union européenne simplement le
processus de négociation ils ont c'est
un processus qui est moteur pour les
réformes en turquie
c'est à dire que la turquie se modernise
grâce à ce processus
donc c'est un processus qui est vraiment
gagnant gagnant et à l'issue de ce
processus
le président de la république a rappelé
que le peuple français auraient à se
prononcer par référendum sur cette
adhésion un référendum loin d'être
d'actualité puisque l'europe n'envisage
pas une entrée de la turquie avant
l'horizon 2020 plusieurs dossiers
restent problématiques notamment les cas
de chypre partiellement occupée depuis
1974 par des structures qu est la
question de la minorité kurde
tiens que nous la communauté kurde nous
sommes favorables à l'inde à choquer
dans l'union européenne mais on ne
demande à l'union européenne de leur
mettre la pression de ré blessés le
monde au respect des droits de l'homme
d'approuver t shirt envers la politique
fort
les drapeaux turcs flotte ici c'est
parce que je suis à l'ambassade de
turquie aux géants des voix pour avoir
les positions officielles du pays
au delà de l'inquiétude que suscite
l'arrivée d'un pays de 76 millions de
musulmans
les insuffisances du régime en termes de
démocratie et frais de plus en plus les
européens
que répondez vous aux critiques
européennes concernant le l'absence de
démocratie du gouvernement actuel
d'erdogan en turquie la turquie a
clairement exprimé sa volonté de
commencer à négocier les chapitres 23 et
24 relatif au pouvoir judiciaire et
droits fondamentaux et pour le chapitre
24 à la justice aux libertés et aux
écuries t cette approche montre s'il
était nécessaire
l'importance accordée à la défense et à
la protection des droits fondamentaux
la turquie en adoptant l'acquis
communautaire pourra encore plus
renforcé sa législation sur ces domaines
là donc on voit le cas de la turquie qui
revient régulièrement dans les
discussions quand même la turquie a
déposé sa demande d'adhésion à l'union
européenne c'était en 1987
c'est à dire juste deux ans après que la
grèce et puis rentrer dans l'union
européenne
quel est le problème selon toi clos est
ce que c'est une question démocratique
uniquement non mais je pense que dans
les critères de copenhague on devrait
rajouter respect du voisin parce que
actuellement il est de la turquie occupe
un pays de l'union européenne occupe
militairement
donc on devrait poser la question juste
à deux chiffres oui de chypre donc
donc je pense que c'est ça qui est le
réel bloquant pas seulement le parlement
turc ne contrôlait plus internet par
exemple c'est des choses comme ça que je
trouve assez inadmissible et erdogan en
novembre lors d'une conférence en
pologne a dit que chypre il n'existe pas
en tant que tant qu'entité donc je
trouve ça pas normal non plus qu'on
laisse passer ce genre de choses est ce
qu'on les laisse vraiment passé parce
que mine de rien depuis 1987 on est
d'accord que la turquie n'arrive pas à
rentrer alors la question c'est est ce
que c'est pour des raisons comme celle
que tu évoques là et qu'ils quittent et
meuse se doit ou alors est ce que ce
sont d'autres raisons en l'occurrence
par exemple la trouille d'avoir 76
millions de
musulmans en europe la turquie pays
laïque oui effectivement c'est un
musulman donc mais là pour rejoindre
parce que c'est ça le blocage selon vous
n'en aurez prône est non franchement non
je pense qu'effectivement ces clous et
c'est ça là je rejoins c'est ce qu'elle
a dit c'est qu'à un moment donné la
turquie il faut qu'elle démontre qu'elle
respecte l'ensemble des règles qui
fondent la communauté européenne et à la
démocratie le respect du voisin mais ça
c'est évident là le respect des
minorités
il ya certain nombre de critères sur
lesquels il faut être effectivement
extrêmement vigilant extrêmement ferme
néanmoins je me vois mal très
franchement l'europe d'hier dans dix ans
même pas parce que sans 2020 dans six
ans dira la turquie au bout d'une si
longue procédure de négociation de
discussion lui redire finalement vous ne
rentrez pas dans l'union européenne
évidemment à condition que la turquie
respecte l'ensemble des critères donc
moi je suis plutôt favorable parce que
de mon point de vue mais encore une fois
ça n'est que ma vérité l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'union européenne peut et
doit stabiliser cette région là apaiser
la région ça pourrait avoir un effet par
rapport à celle adressée ça pourrait
avoir un effet positif mais je suis pas
contre l'adhésion mais si je les paie
ses efforts vous avez raison moi je
voudrais évoquer puisqu'on a parlé de
voyages d'hollande
en turquie avec erdogan là on parle
encore de la reconnaissance du génocide
arménien de 1915 par exemple que la
turquie n'était pas un coeur avoué entre
guillemets et on disait sous les
journaux français que dans les mots de
landes
il n'y avait pas le mot génocide
pourquoi parce qu'ils avaient peur qui
se serait fâché les turcs
donc ne pas avouer un génocide dans
l'histoire je crois que c'est ça ça ça
ne dit beaucoup de choses à un niveau 2
au niveau de l'ouverture mentale
démocratique des turcs a donc pour toi
on revient à une question qui est plus
de l'ordre démocratique depuis tout à
l'heure
donc soit disant en fait c'est vrai que
la turquie actuellement le gouvernement
d'erdogan ne respecte pas les droits
démocratiques de son peuple
on l'a vu à taksim etc c'est pas que ça
comme question parce que le gouvernement
français parlent de démocratie etc
en parallèle ils passent des accords de
coopération soi disant anti terroriste
avec le gouvernement turc et l'a envoyé
des kurdes il ya plusieurs dizaines de
kurdes de militants progressistes kurdes
actuellement incarcérés en france sous
mais sur ordre d'ankara il ya une
question économique voici derrière peut
être que martin que monsieur martin
connaît excusez moi mais là ce sera très
bien peut-être que les doigts reconnaît
la situation a des usines renault en
turquie en turquie dans la ville de
bourg sont produites les clio 4 qui
arrive en europe les salariés ils n'ont
pas du tout droit de grève là bas n'ont
pas le droit de grève
ils sont payer un salaire de misère
c'est des ouvriers très qualifiés
pourtant et ça profite bien aux
entreprises européennes l'allemagne a
beaucoup de parts de marché en turquie
la france a beaucoup parts de marché en
turquie qu'est ce que tu veux dire ce
que je veux dire c'est que en fait la
turquie actuellement dans l'état actuel
des choses elle est très utile elle est
pas dans l'union européenne comme ça on
n'est pas obligé de mettre les mêmes
droits syndicaux etc
par contre on produit beaucoup beaucoup
de deux produits
je relance sur ce que tu dis est ce que
finalement la question qui se pose c'est
que l'union européenne doit avoir des
frontières totalement net par exemple tu
disais aujourd'hui le rapport avec la
turquie
et bien c'est tout simplement qu'on a
des accords on s'entend et finalement
l'intégrer ou pas c'est pas forcément ça
qui va compter dans le rapport qu'on a
économique avec la turquie
est ce qu'il n'ya pas d'autres formes
d'accords est ce qu'on doit
obligatoirement intégrer les pays
dans l'union européenne pour que l'union
européenne ait une réelle assise
la preuve que non regardez l'exemple
avec la suisse la suisse n'est pas
membre de l'union européenne pourtant je
veux dire la suisse ne vit que grâce et
et par l'europe et tous les accords
commerciaux sur la coopération suisse
l'europe cette année que des accords
quasiment commerciaux quoi donc
mais après un moment donné je vous dise
et séquelles quelle est la vision que
nous voulons avoir du rôle qu'ils
doivent jouer l'europe
et je parle pas uniquement en termes de
frontières géographiques
même si effectivement abandonné il faut
peut-être qu'imiter l'espace on peut par
englober non plus la terre entière mais
c'est la question la turquie encore une
fois moi j'ai je suis d'accord la
turquie ou non peut pas dire qu'elle
respecte l'ensemble des règles
démocratiques
il ya encore des minorités qui sont le
plat de chypre il faut vraiment trancher
cette question là il faut je veux dire
on ne peut pas attirer un pays de
l'union européenne tant qu'ils soient
pas totalement transparente et que ce
soit clair de part et d'autre sinon on
va à la catastrophe mais relation est
une chance alors comme ça on règle ses
problèmes une fois pour toutes si on y
arrive d'ici 2020 on pourrait enfin
faire un pas en avant
je suis pas bloqué ensuite la turquie
n'a pas fait d'efforts depuis nice et
pour ça il faut énormément d'efforts et
c'est aussi à nous de faire un effort et
négocier avec 95 vous avez le mot de la
fin je vous préviens d'accord que le
pression non simplement pour dire
l'europe a une responsabilité vis-à-vis
de ses voisins on ne peut pas faire
comme si on était au milieu de nulle
part
que ce soit le maghreb que ce soit
l'ukraine et cetera il faut qu'on soit
attentif et j'ai presque envie de dire
le projet européen aussi pourquoi ces
migrants qui viennent d'afrique et
d'asie tués deux par tous veulent venir
en europe
c'est pas un truc mais pourront faire
chier c'est parce qu'ils viennent de
pays où c'est la misère sociale c'est la
dictature où ils leur vie étant est en
danger donc il se dit voilà l'europe va
me protéger moi ma famille donc j'ai
simplement envie de dire que si l'europe
ne prend pas en compte cette situation
là et s'il ne fait pas des efforts pour
aider ces pays là à
à retrouver la démocratie avoir une
stabilité économique à voir une
croissance économique etc
il n'y aura jamais assez de grillage
assez haut il n'aura jamais assez de
barbelés à ces coupes en pour éviter que
ces gens là au détriment de leur vie et
celle de les traverser
je suis né dans un pays où il ya une
enclave au maroc qui s'appelle ceuta et
l'europe a fait vivement
des grillages monstrueux avec des
barbelés bat tous les jours
malheureusement on retrouve des cadavres
des gens qui essayent de passer ces
grillages donc
imaginons un peu ce qui peut se passer
dans cette tête là et le rôle et le rôle
politique aussi des citoyens européens
que nous sommes si on ne peut pas vivre
heureux sachant que de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée ou ailleurs il ya des
gens qui meurent de faim c'est pas
possible c'est ça aussi
votre rêve européen edouard martin merci
beaucoup de faire ce droit puisse
rayonner au delà des frontières c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui permettra de
mieux délimiter les frontières
merci à chacun d'entre vous génération
grâce est terminé à très bientôt